hallo freunde sieht man kein bildschirm
[Musik]
ich mag bitte dreht nicht draußen ihr
seid zu laut für meine nachbarn ja nach
was wir machen das schon tag erster satz
manchmal dass ich es tut mir leid naja
wollen da ist ein letztes mal sehr gut
gefallen hat uns beim essen zu
beobachten macht mir das heute noch mal
es gibt pizza die server wigan es gibt
vegane seine arbeit pizza man denken
wieso veganer könnten sich nur gesund
ernähren aber meinen schinken ist auch
heftigst vegan war ja in gedanken an
jakob küppers der heute leider nicht
dabei sein kann schauen wir uns an was
beim letzten video ab ging es war sehr
spaßig viel spaß
auch dieses mal haben wir auch instagram
nach witzigen fragen oder anmerkungen
gefragt was du warum gekommen ist habe
ich wenn mehr zählen solche videos
glaube kommen wirklich am besten sie so
crazy ist bei mir wenn ich spiegel fotos
macht kommen die auch im westen
warum macht ihr immer den leichtesten
content zum beleg warum bildet die so
deswegen ist so köln fünf sechs sieben
mal kurze anekdote ich hatte die beste
youtube idee 2009/10 wollte mich bei
hilf mir bewerben damit sebastian hilf
mir rein guckt und so antwortet da wird
es dabei aber klar ich bin zum casting
gegangen ich wurde genommen das problem
es ist ja die haben gar nicht für hilft
mir gekostet aber seitdem bekomme ich
jeden tag nachrichten ob ich bei köln
50667 worden
und ich schreibe dir immer so alter
bitte hört auf mir zu schreiben ich will
das nicht und die melden sich dann hier
ist carsten von köln 50667 hast du lust
auf eine hauptrolle schon ein alter hut
mich anzurufen
warum das könnte deine frau seien in der
welt des tv serien stars den ganzen nach
oben zu klettern der durchbruch was
studierst du bist mit dem bericht gehe
heute mit kapuze aber es liegt nur daran
dass die empfehlung eines friseurs von
einem kumpel von media absoluter
reinfall war und ich meine haare jetzt
nichts sagen kann ist geduld niemals in
die sauna gehen nieder als nicht alter
witzige story
ich kannte ihn eine woche und hat
gefragt ob wir zusammen in die therme
gehen wollen ich dachte so etwas hätte
ich nicht von ihm gedacht so aber ja
packst du meine tasche packen ist ein
was ich brauche bademantel und so wir
stehen davor und sagt oh ja ich wette
[ __ ] hat seine badehose vergessen hat
die partie gehen denn der therme so
braucht eine badehose aber wir sind in
der thermik
der mann war zu sehen gibt und nicht
arbeit so krass dass der in die sauna
gehen will aber ich bin dabei und hatte
nichts mit da muss ich mir für 50 euro
bekommen jetzt habe ich hier nicht mal
mehr als überdramatisieren damit die
leute geflasht es hat wieder jemand über
eine schick 39 vom letzten mal wollte
mich mal wieder am leben sein edel
wieder an meinen schmerzen erkennen was
der markt genauso wie der dritte mit
raus erfolgskonzept never change a
winning system nur meine beste ist es
wieder zeit
du hast wieder die chance zu gewinnen
letztes mal hast du am schwarzen nicht
erkannt was wir essen schloss im
nächsten versuch okay jana wird gebeten
[Musik]
was willst du nicht nur eine bescheidene
junge frau somit wird mir da ein paar
linke schickt ihr 99
angedacht seien drauf wichtigsten euro
dann stecken wir jetzt ein euro meine
beste hast du dich noch mal für die
parallelwelten interessiert nein bis
jetzt ich glaube die talkshow oder so
also mehr läufen und einer aus erfahrung
weiß ich dass du die an die apps auf die
man sich freut nie krass sind weil ja
ich bügele es einblick geben die geben
ich glaube ich auch meistens auf so
diese anderen rap deutschland leute wo
dann auch noch nicht so viele sind sogar
ein talent ich kann beanstanden
helden ganz kurz festhalten bis nach
interessanten fragen gegoogelt hab mit
dem riesen titel 270 interessante fragen
in der liste für das interessante fragen
bleiben
die ersten fragen sind gibt es
erfahrungen die dein leben nachhaltig
verändert hat bei welchem film längst du
laut an zu wachen
nach so lachen
deutschlands bester newcomer rapper wird
uns jetzt ein paar fragen stellen
da ich stelle euch 36 fragen und nach
diesen fragen sehr verliebt doch ich
glaube an den test ich bin ein großer
ist eric freund deswegen ein bisschen
angst davor
ok erste frage wenn du dich für eine
beliebige person entscheiden könnte ist
wen hättest du gern als gast an allen
masc
[Musik]
spenden sie unterstellen
wärst du gerne berühmt mit
was meinst du wie ich die ganze scheiße
hier machen geldgeber und bildschirm
walter und ich es jemals geübt dass du
sagen willst warum jemand an junge jedes
reihe von ihm telefoniert ist wien
aktuell für mich jetzt noch mehr auf ihn
nackt sein
geil was macht für dich einen perfekten
tag aus perfekten tag zu langsam habe
ich schon ein bisschen
er hat heute sein gewissen langsam
nächstes wann hast du das letzte mal für
sich selbst gesungen oder für jemand
anderen dann hast du das letzte mal
etwas zum ersten mal gemacht
jetzt wann hast du das letzte mal für
dich selbst gesund oder mache ich nie
das ding von morgens bis abends
eigentlich durch langweilig meisterfrage
wenn es hier möglich wäre 90 jahre alt
werden ab dem alter von 30 entweder den
körper oder den geist eines 30-jährigen
für die letzten 60 jahre des lebens
gehalten was von beiden präsidenten
nämlich 60 werden wird 90 jahre alt ich
würde den körper behalten weil wir ist
ja weise über die jahre
ja sagt ich habe keine eingeweide
überträgt hörte sich stale loco nennen
drei dinge die du und dein gegenüber
anscheinend gemeinsam haben guten style
viel geld ähnliche mentalität
ähnlich der jagd wofür in deinem leben
des von bank passt das geld die [ __ ]
ist bei jeder frage geld beliebig geld
man gibt es geld geht dann nur
bildschirm das hat aber die tage für
bisschen dankbar ist meine träume
verwirklichen zu können in freiheit zu
leben
wer ohne job ich glaube so in almanya zu
sein ohne irgend jetzt nationalistischen
gedacht haben in einem land zu leben wo
wir komplett sind und können was wir tun
wollen dass du richtig bei mir ist es so
dass ich sehr dankbar dafür wenn das ich
gerade mit instagram und youtube unsere
mir so eine basis geschaffen habe
relativ frei zu gucken was ich jetzt
machen wir hier gerade einfach auf
entspannt nebenbei studieren werden kann
ohne den druck zu haben direkt an kunden
kommen zu müssen und sowas sondern
einfach so nebenbei bisschen schicken wo
man hin möchte
na gut du bist aber du hast ja nebenbei
noch ein bisschen tätowieren und macht
so folter youtube folter im installiert
vollzeitstudium und dann machst du den
ball noch die sie so eine tour und wenn
du irgendwas an der art und weise wie du
erzogen wurde das ändern kann
was wäre das alte geendet diesen keine
serie zeichentrick nur kicker bei rtl
ist der teufel und disney und so
eigentlich auch toll findet nemo gesehen
auf das war's eigentlich glaube ich
eigentlich auch alles locker vielleicht
das zu tun hat was mit der erziehung von
meinen eltern zu tun die würden
vielleicht ein bisschen zu locker
in manchen hinsicht also soll die
sicherheit vor nicht so ich liebe dich
über alles und deshalb auch gar kein
frosch wird das auch immer witzig aber
leute die vielleicht nicht damit
klarkommt werden können nicht damit
sagen aber ich weiß jetzt ihnen mein
freund mit meinen eltern klar kommen
würde weil die halt direkt so sehr offen
wird wenn der eine kristallkugel die
wahrheit über dich dein leben deine
zukunft und alles andere verraten würden
was würdest du wissen zu gute frage ob
man braucht man überhaupt irgendwas
wissen will
ich würde eigentlich gerne wissen wie
alt ich werde aber nur so uns zu wissen
und dann würdest du gern wieder
vergessen ansonsten wird hier komplett
paranoid werden das zeigt wie so ein ja
aber das wird gern wissen also was ich
kann mir halt also ganz ohne das
irgendwie jetzt übertrieben oder komisch
klingt ich kann mir nicht vorstellen als
merken es geht mein kopf überhaupt nicht
rein das war auch die zeit gerne wie sie
jetzt machen müssen
dann heißt es selbst weil ich weiß nicht
ob ich 30 werde die leute wenn ihr nicht
wisst was ihr beim ersten date machen
soll jetzt aber ihr seid schon ein
bisschen in love differenzial das nicht
ich nicht weiß wer ich diese frage
stellen würde
ich habe einen ganz klaren sind dass sie
nicht einschneiden aber das funktioniert
immer witzig der date doktor gucken
funktioniert immer
[Musik]